despite performing poorly upon release
both critically and commercially 1995's
Empire Records has gone on to become a
coming-of-age classic gradually amassing
a cult following in the decade sent for
some of the cast members Empire Records
of the launching pad for long and
fruitful careers
Perez errs the beloved teen flick wound
up being their pinnacle here's what the
cast of Empire Records looks like today
Liv Tyler Cory after her Rockstar dad
Steven Tyler cast her in the music video
for Aerosmith's hit song crazy lives
Tyler landed her first major movie role
as overachieving student Cory in Empire
Records co-star Maxwell Caulfield later
admitted that the male cast members
found it hard to keep their eyes off
this emerging Swan prompting Tyler's
mother to remain on set so she could
keep her daughter's admirers in check
since then Tyler gained worldwide fame
playing elf Maiden Darwin in Peter
Jackson's The Lord of the Rings trilogy
more recently she started as a regular
on the HBO series the leftovers and
she's moved into producing pulling the
strings on the fantasy horror project
modeling which stars Tyler opposite belt
Holly and Brad Dourif
coyote shivers Berko while it's true
that Liv Tyler's mother bebe Buell
provided a chaperone service for her
daughter on set there was actually a
second reason for her being there Buell
Married Berko actor Frances coyote
shivers in 1992 meaning that Tyler was
acting alongside her 24 year old stepdad
and Empire Records with her mother
watching over them both cool shivers and
bull divorced in 1999 and he had since
worked as a musician and DJ in the Los
Angeles area so as club work was put on
hold in September 2015 when he started a
nine-month prison sentence for violating
the terms of a restraining order filed
against them by a second white pauley
perrette Renee Zellweger Jena after
making her debut opposite fellow unknown
Matthew McConaughey in the 1994 flop
Texas Chainsaw Massacre the next
generation Renee Zellweger rebounded
with a breakthrough role as Gina an
empire record she ended up writing that
buzz to superstardom and Jerry Maguire
and later won an Academy Award for her
performance in 2003 as Cold Mountain of
course everyone knows what Zellweger
looks like these days because of an
ongoing tabloid controversy over whether
or not she's had plastic surgery to
change her looks del Wenger has risen
above the nonsense and continues to
perform in films like Bridget Jones baby
and same kind of different as me
Rory Cochrane Lucas few young actors
were as ubiquitous in the 90s as Rory
Cochrane who appeared in 10 films that
decade including dog town and Dazed and
Confused these days he's best known for
starring in 50 episodes of CSI Miami at
Timothy Speidel though he continues to
appear on the big screen as a character
actor in films like Argo and black Matt
Robin Tunney Deborah with their shaved
head Robin Tunney caught the attention
of Hollywood as suicidal team Deborah in
Empire Records that led to roles in a
string of big budget blockbusters but
the gravy train derailed when 2000
supernova became a super flop though she
continued to appear in minor films then
tony has found more success on the small
screen appearing in over 150 episodes of
the Mentalist as Teresa Lisbon ethan
embry mark the definition of a working
actor ethan embry has appeared in film
and on television every single year
since Empire Records came out in 1995
even if you may not remember any of
those appearances while his most famous
role is probably as rusty Griswold in
Vegas vacation Embry is still going
strong with guest spots on shows like
The Walking Dead and Once Upon a Time
pretty good work if you don't mind
getting literally eaten alive Johnny
Whitworth AJ though he's best known for
his role as AJ and Empire Records
Johnny Whitworth almost played a totally
different character he initially wanted
to play the part of Lucas instead he
told Star emag I wanted to be Lucas
because he had great one-liners but he
didn't get the kids Liv Tyler at the end
everything comes together as God intends
it so special and you're so talented and
you have everything it's making more
than everything it takes when you're
really stupid because you don't know
that since then
the Almighty has apparently intended
whitworth to become a TV star as we've
had reoccurring roles on CSI Miami the
100 and blind-spot
Anthony LaPaglia Joe Australian actor
Anthony LaPaglia was a late bloomer as a
thespian moving to New York City in his
early 20s in the hope of one day
becoming an actor by the late 80s he was
regularly landing gigs eventually
leading to his role as Joe an empire
record since then he's become most
famous for his Golden Globe winning turn
as suicidal FBI agent Jack Malone in the
CBS drama without a trace
superb
aniconic superb Maxwell Caulfield Rex
Manning washed-up musician Rex Manning
was the butt of the joke at Empire
Records but actor Maxwell Caulfield is
anything but washed-up though some may
know I'm best for his role as Manning
Caulfield has actually appeared in
nearly 40 feature films while also
working on stage and providing voices
for audiobooks cartoons and video games
they know more and you were my favorite
singer in high school did your paper say
yes it's do you
debi mazar Jane Empire Records is just
one of many major motion pictures where
you may have seen Debi Mazar
she's also appeared in films like
Goodfellas Malcolm X and Batman Forever
she's since gone on to star in
television as well with a reoccurring
role as publicist Shauna in Entourage if
that weren't enough she and her husband
Gabriel Korkis had their own show on The
Cooking Channel Brendon Sexton Warren
before playing Warren in Empire Records
Brendon Sexton had already earned an
Independent Spirit Awards nomination for
his role and welcomes the dollhouse that
was pretty much the highlight of his
career though he continues to appear as
the character actor and ensemble like
Black Hawk Down which he later publicly
criticized for the film's portrayal of
somalis James kima will Eddie not
everyone is cut out to be a superstar
Kimo wills is one of those folks as the
guy who played Eddie has since pretty
much dropped out of acting altogether
after a string of appearances as extras
and other minor characters these days
he's just a normal dude doing things
like playing video games reading comics
and retweeting cute dog photos hey the
world needs regular folks too thanks for
watching click the blooper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check all this cool stuff we know you'll
love to
you
[Music]